wird aber gerne Johannes Vogel gleich zu
Beginn fragen wie würden sie die
Situation im Moment beschreiben ist das
so eine Dreier Paartherapie die da
gerade stattfindet oder ist es eher in
vor Gericht in Meseberg in Wahrheit ist
es einfach ein Parteiensystem neuer Art
ich glaube das kommt nicht mehr zurück
das wäre irgendwie zwei Parteien haben
die koalieren die sich zu 80% einig sind
und dann nur noch 20% diskutieren müssen
hinter den Kulissen diskutieren und dann
sagen so wird es jetzt gemacht sondern
ich glaube durch dieses veränderte
Parteiensystem was wir ja alle wählen
als Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben wir
eben die Situation ganz unterschiedliche
Parteien müssen koalieren und dann
gibt's auch Debatte was können sie nicht
zu den Leuten jetzt schieben sie
gestalten
uns alle als Gesellschaft ich wollte nur
sagen dass sie sagen besser geht's nicht
sagen sie nee ich will damit sagen die
Unterschiedlichkeit bei diesem Parteien
wird bleiben und trotzdem muss man was
Gutes fürs Land erreichen und das muss
doch der Maßstab sein ich finde nicht ob
debattiert ja
wir kriegen es ja bei Themen hin über
die wir oft zu wenig reden wir haben das
Einwanderungsrecht reformiert
Punktesystem aller Kanada wir machen
Infrastrukturprojekte endlich schneller
also es passt liegen ja Dinge über die
reden wir wenig wir reden über die die
gestritten wird und ich sage ganz
ehrlich ich bin ja nicht Mitglied der
Regierung als Parlamentarier ich fand
jetzt dieses Aufhalten des
wachstumsschancengesetz auch unnötig
also manchmal wird auch gestritten und
das muss nicht sein
ist das normaler politischer Streit Frau
Mann was wir da gerade sehen ich meine
wachstumschancengesetz soll morgen
glaube ich dann durchgehen ja heute vom
Kabinett beschlossen genau
schnell durch den Bundestag weil für
mehr Wirtschaft ja genau
also ist das noch normaler politischer
Streit wenn ein Finanzminister der
dieses wachstumschossen Gesetzt ja zum
zum wichtigen wichtige Sache erklärt hat
bereits eine Pressekonferenz ankündigt
war unter anderem auch
Kolleginnen Kollegen das vorstellen will
und muss diese Pressekonferenz dann
wieder mehr oder weniger klammheimlich
einkassieren weil dann Frau pauss sagt
nee das wollen wir doch alles nicht so
obwohl es bereits verabredet war ja
normales daran nichts würde ich sagen
also an allem was man den letzten sechs
Monaten vielleicht erlebt haben ich
finde herr Vogel hat total recht dass
hier drei Partner zusammengefunden haben
die in der Konstellation noch nie
zusammengefunden haben aber das
Interessante ist ja dass diese Ampel am
Anfang ganz gut miteinander gearbeitet
hat also man könnte ja denken am Anfang
ruckelt ist dann spielen sich die Dinge
ein und dann wird eben immer weiter und
immer idealerweise immer professioneller
regiert bei der Ampel ist ja umgekehrt
die haben am Anfang gerade in der
Krisenphase Kriegsbeginn ziemlich viel
auf die Kette gekriegt ziemlich viele
sehr schnelle Entscheidungen sehr
praktizieren ja und jetzt auf einmal wo
man denken sollte sie sind eingespielt
wir haben ja bald Halbzeit der Koalition
im Dezember zwischen Halbzeit der
Koalition das ist ja so lange nicht mehr
hin auf einmal ruckelt es immer immer
mehr dass man oder man muss ja fast
sagen fliegen so aus der Kurve
regelmäßig und das finde ich ist eine
Entwicklung die zeigt dass die noch
nicht zueinander gefunden haben das ist
im Gegenteil sich immer weiter
auseinander entwickelt vielleicht er hat
es auch was damit zu tun dass die Phasen
so unterschiedlich sind ich will es
nicht entschuldigen ich habe mich am
meisten darüber geärgert dass dieser
Post das Wachstumschancen selbst
aufgehalten hat und das auch unnötig
dass alles gesagt so aber wir haben ja
auch schon glücklich geworden
total gesagt ähm wir haben total Knüppel
geschmissen nee ich sage haben sie
gesagt ich wollte ja ich wollte sagen
ich sag nicht dass wir unschuldig sind
interessant ne sie schmeißen nee das
wollte ich mir nicht zeigen machen
sondern ich wollte Dir zeigen machen
dass wir zum Beispiel das GG von Robert
Habeck aufgehalten haben weil wir
glauben es musste sich wirklich um 180
Grad drehen davon bin ich auch überzeugt
so hatten sie auch schon verabredet nee
das ist stellen die Kollegen in der
Regierung unterschiedlich da in jedem
Fall was so nicht verabschiedungsreife
es wäre falsch gewesen so das finde ich
auch muss in der Politik gehen aber ich
will den Punkt machen
mal Krisenbewältigung ist das eine und
da finde ich auch wir sind besser durch
den Winter gekommen als viele gedacht
hatten letztes Jahr aber jetzt wusste
ist dass Sie die Vorlage sofort nehmen
würden
gerne auch zu dem Teil kommen der so ein
bisschen komplizierter ist nee jetzt
kommen wir doch in Wahrheit in die Phase
dass uns das meine ich als Gesellschaft
einholt das wäre über zehn Jahre
Wirtschaftswachstum nicht genutzt haben
die Grundlagen zu legen für den nächsten
Aufschwung zehn Jahre das
interessantes ja da in 2009 auch mal mit
regiert ich will da gar niemanden
rauslassen ich will sagen zehn Jahre da
waren sie gerade raus die anderen sagen
immer
zehn Jahre und war gerade gesagt ich
nehme die FDP meine Partei da gar nicht
aus aber vielleicht können wir was
ändern wollen müssen wir analysieren wo
kommst her mein Gefühl ist wir sind die
großen Aufgaben nicht angegangen und
jetzt holt uns das ein oder andere vor
Corona schon was unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit angeht in allen
Parametern dann immer weiter
zurückfielen so und das müssen wir jetzt
ändern auf den Weg haben wir uns seit
Anfang des Jahres auch gemacht ich habe
eben Beispiele genannt aber in diesem
Bereich Wirtschaftspolitik ökonomische
Zukunft da brechen natürlich die die
Konflikte auch stärker auf weil zum
Beispiel die Grünen und Bier und
offensichtlich unterschiedlich einfach
genetisch nicht zusammen
30 Sekunden ist eine reine Männer
dominierte Partei die Grünen sind ganz
anders ja ihr habt ein ganz geringen
Frauenanteil ist immer das Problem
nichts dagegen dass man die Frauen
Kompetenz hervorhebt aber das ist
wirklich das Problem der FDP ist weil
sie nicht strukturelles Problem wie hoch
ist
relativ gering ein großes Problem immer
wieder gesprochen es gibt keinen
weiblichen Nachwuchs in der fdpd anders
sind die Grüns ist da wird die Partei
von Frauen gelenkt und geführt und
gestaltet und ich denke da passen dann
diese männerwelten
einfach auch wenn dann lisa-paus davor
sitzt und Steffi Lemke und es passt
nicht zusammen
man schaut dazu wie jeder kleinste
Konflikt auf offener Bühne ausgetragen
wird man geht es jetzt aus den
Sommerpause und geht noch zu Hause da
wieder raus das wollen die Bürger nicht
aber wollen die Leute draußen nicht dass
jeder kleinste Konflikt öffentlich wird
die 30 Sekunden habe ich gerne 45 €.
okay
die ist nicht hoch genug ist sie und sie
sagten die ist glaube ich höher
die ist nicht gut genug wir müssen mehr
Frauen in der Mitgliedschaft haben die
ist irgendwo unter um die 30 aber unter
30 leider so aber dass wir gar keine
weiblichen Kollegen haben das schon
unter 30 € 15 Zahlen nicht im Kopf ist
sehr gering ja sie ist aber es stimmt
nicht dass wir keine tollen Kolleginnen
in der FDP hätten aber die schärfste
Kritikerin übrigens von dieser Pause in
den letzten Wochen war meine tolle
Kollegen Jensen die lohnt sich übrigens
auch mal dann hier vielleicht einzuladen
weil die gerade erklärt hat dass der
Unterschied glaube ich nicht in dieser
Frage über die wir gerade reden
Geschlechter spezifischer Blick auf die
Lage ist und Unterschied ist ganz klar
wir glauben es muss erst erwirtschaftet
werden was zum Beispiel auch ein
Sozialstaat verteilt werden muss wir
glauben darüber reden genauso wie ich
wir glauben dass im sozialstand ist um
mehr Aufstiegschancen gehen sollte und
nicht um materielle leistungsausweitung
wir glauben die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unseres Landes muss besser werden weil
Unternehmer nicht böse sind und
Unternehmerinnen sondern gute
Rahmenbedingungen brauchen das sind
Unterschiede zwischen Parteien sogar
Leute herr Vogel gibt ja sogar Leute die
sprechen von sozial Klimbim ja das ist
nicht meine Wortwahl und das hat sich
der
Kollege aus ihrer Partei ja der hat sich
zurecht auch dafür entschuldigt weil
Sozia hat er sich entschuldigt ja
öffentlich da wo er das gesagt hat er
auch eingeräumt falsche Wortwahl war
sozial Klimbim ja die ehemalige Leiter
der Arbeitsagentur Wuppertal Solingen
Mitarbeiter und viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger um die wir uns gekümmert haben
und ich glaube ich bin nicht im Verdacht
haben sie mal angerufen bin bin so ein
Bord kommt ganz sicher zu Recht dafür
entschuldigt haben sie ihn angerufen
er hat sich ja zu Recht dafür
entschuldigt so aber was verheerend ne
wenn man sowas so sagt wir wissen das
Diskutieren nicht für förderlich aber
hinter dieser Debatte können wir den
Sozialstaat einfach ausweiten oder
müssen wir ihn treffsicher machen
oder kann man dann einfach eine
sozialstaatsreform machen und dafür ein
wachstumsgesetz einhalten die Debatte
ist berechtigt denn da teile ich die
Kritik an dieser Pausen wie schaut der
Historiker drauf gibt ja es ist heute
tatsächlich auch ein bisschen
Geschichtsstunde auch mit dem was wir
gleich von Reinhold Beckmann hören
werden in diesem wirklich sehr berühren
im Buch aufgeschrieben hat
gibt ja manche Kollegen die sagen dass
das riecht schon so ein bisschen nach
Weimar dann gibt es natürlich sagen auf
gar keinen Fall unsere Demokratie ist
wehrhaft die Radikalisierung der Mitte
von der Reinhold Beckmann sagt das ist
spürbar die wird aber trotzdem nicht
dazu führen dass dann irgendwann
rechtsextreme Parteien übernehmen gerade
in dem Buch von Uwe Wittstock heißt er
glaube ich ne gelesen Februar 33 ist
dann unglaublich gutes Buch in dem man
beschreibt dass die oder wie die Nazis
genau einen Monat gebraucht haben um das
ganze
System auszuheben also halte von diesem
Vergleich mit meinen nicht so sehr sehr
viel denn die die Grundvoraussetzungen
waren völlig andere wir hatten einen
verlorenen Ersten Weltkrieg in Europa
mit mit Massenarbeitslosigkeit und wir
haben ja auch das Anwachsen beide
extremer Ränder gab es doch nicht
vergessen eines der unterkpd die Linke
ist gerade weil sie so zerlegen damals
in Form also vor 33 und aber wir sehen
natürlich
auch Parallelen also das Ende der
Volksparteien also ein Problem Weimarer
Parteien war dass sie nur
Klientelpolitik gemacht haben und die
letzte Weimarer Koalition demokratisch
bestimmt scheitert an der Frage der
Arbeitslosenversicherung eine wie viel
Prozent und danach kommen die
präsidiarkabinente die ohne Mehrheit im
Reichstag regieren und was wir also die
Gefahr die wir natürlich sehen ist denke
man mal hier anwachsende AFD wir sehen
das schon in den Ländern also ich dann
demokratische Koalition bilden die
eigentlich nichts gemeinsam haben die
die sich eigentlich bekämpfen und die
trotzdem und als vierer-koalition und
die natürlich in der Bürger und die
Bürgerin sagt ihr müsst gute Arbeit
machen ihr müsst handeln sie handeln
aber nicht weil sie sich gegenseitig
blockieren und das führt zu großer
Frustration und das kann dann
Teufelskreis werden natürlich schon dass
unsere Demokratie fragil ist in ihren in
ihren Strukturen Abläufen ja dass man
natürlich das ist auch die große Angst
vor den Landtag so einem Osten im
nächsten Jahr mit dass man sozusagen
schon wenn man keine Regierung mehr
bilden kann wenn keine Mehrheit mehr
zustande kommt wie in Thüringen ja zur
Zeit wo die ja seit Jahren vor sich hin
regieren ohne irgendwie ohne eine echte
Mehrheit du kannst ja mit wenigen
Gesetzesvorhaben auch die die auf
einfach gesetzlicher Ebene kannst du ja
schon Strukturen der Demokratie ändern
die tiefgreifende Folgen haben aber vor
allen Dingen also wir brauchen ja
eigentlich ein Handeln das Staat muss
handeln in der Situation das spüren wir
glaube ich alle wenn man durch
Deutschland fährt ist es gibt keinen
erkenntnisdefizit es gibt
unterschiedliche Lösungsansätze man will
dass die Politik handelt und Probleme
lösen löst und wenn wir aber
Konstellation haben denen das nicht
möglich ist weil sich die Parteien
selbst blockieren weil sie ja
unterschiedliche Ansätze haben dann
haben wir ein riesen Problem da steht
dann doch der Vergleich zur Weimarer
Republik an der Kanzler anordner
Konstellation so wenn man jetzt mal
guckt der wirtschaftliche Druck bei uns
ist ja überall zu spüren in vielen
Bereichen in mittelständischen
Unternehmen ob ganz oben aber auch ganz
unten wenn jemand auf dem Land sein
Lebenstraum verwirklichen will der immer
möglich war und ein Handwerker der sich
ein Haus bauen möchte ein kleines Haus
hat 200.000 vielleicht sich
zusammengespart ein bisschen aus der
Verwandtschaft ein bisschen zurückgelegt
und ihn das restliche oder sich von der
Kreissparkasse und geht hin ich brauche
diesen Kredit und mein Lebenstraum zu
verbinden möchte meine Frau heiraten
möchte mein kleines Haus bauen das ist
jetzt nicht mehr möglich in diesem
Moment bei dem Zinssatz den er bei der
Bank bezahlen muss dafür und bei denen
man sagt Zement kostet jetzt 50 % mehr
die anderen Baustoffe ebenfalls eine
riesen Problem diese Träume werden nicht
mehr möglich gemacht und das erzeugt
natürlich irgendwie diese Frustration ja
wenn dann das politisch auch noch
vorgelebt wird das meine ich vorhin mit
diesen ewigen Streitereien dann sind das
potentielle Denkzettel Wähler die gehen
dann schon mal zur AFD und machen da mal
ein kleines Kreuzchen weil man auch
sagen musste die AFD ist nicht die nsdp
wir haben bei Weimar also das führt in
den Holocaust in die Schuhe und wir
reden ja noch über Vernichtungskrieg und
so weiter genau also es gibt natürlich
parallelen es gibt Demokratien
häufig lese und Merkel da gibt es große
Uneinigkeit auch auf Historiker Seite
die einen sagen ob gar keinen Fall ist
dass der Weg dahin weil die Situation so
wie sie es auch beschreiben nicht
wirklich vergleichbar ist aber es gibt
dann doch noch Parallelen und es ist
dann auch immer die Frage Melanie Ammann
wie haben sie das wahrgenommen als
Christian Lindner jetzt im Zusammenhang
mit dem mit der Kindergrundsicherung mit
dem mit dem mit der Frage ob es diese
Milliarden jetzt gibt oder nicht wie
plötzlich so dieser Zungenschlag da
reinkam der so sagte da gibt es diesen
sehr eindeutigen Zusammenhang er hat
zwischen
Kindergrundsicherung sehr sehr hohen
Ausgaben dafür und ähm er hat gesagt
dass die Kinder sozusagen dass die große
Zahl der bedürftigen Kinder sozusagen
oder der der der Familien mit mit
Kindern die wirtschaftlich schwach sind
das dann hoher Zahl besonders
ukrainische Flüchtlinge und ich finde
das schon befremdlich weil was ist die
Konsequenz daraus man soll generell
keine sich alles tun als Politiker wäre
mein Gefühl um bedürftigen Kindern im
eigenen Land zu helfen egal völlig
unabhängig von der Staatsangehörigkeit
meine Lindner ist gerade in die Ukraine
gefahren hat dort auch irgendwie noch
mal die Solidarität der Bundesregierung
betont ganz betroffen sich die
Zerstörung angeschaut und dann sozusagen
im zeitlichen Kontext war so eine
Äußerung gefallen davor und ja das finde
ich einfach unglaubwürdig und finde ich
auch problematisch dann eine gerade
schon bei Kindern eine zwei
Klassengesellschaft einzuführen wenn man
so will die die mehr Förderung kriegen
sollten es riecht auch so wie vielleicht
ein Problem sind oder so also der Reflex
ist auch es klingt so ein bisschen nach
der Suche nach dem Sündenbock also wer
wer war es jetzt und was kostet da so
viel Geld und was müssen wir denn
eigentlich tun
Melanie Ammann hat es gerade angedeutet
herr Vogel die Zahlen auf den ersten
Blick geben ihm mehr durchaus recht
sehen Sie das auch so ja er hat einfach
die Fakten die Statistik zitiert ja die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit stellt das da
und seine Aussagen gehen dann ja weiter
weil es geht ja um die Frage dahinter
stand ja die folgende Debatte wie
bringen wir Kinder aus der Armut raus
und da steht gibt's zwei Denkschulen und
die wurden gerade auch aus debattiert
wollen wir die Transferleistungen ihrem
Grundniveau noch weiter erhöhen oder
machen wir uns Gedanken wie bringen wir
die Menschen raus z.B indem sie in
Arbeit bringen finanzielle
selbstständigkeiten die wir dafür sorgen
dass bildungsleistung auch in Anspruch
genommen werden von Familien die weniger
Geld haben das Materielle Leistung die
Familien die weniger Geld zur Verfügung
stehen in Anspruch genommen werden da
gibt's nämlich in die Lage übrigens
katastrophal ja z.B die bildungsleistung
80% der Familien den sie zustehen würden
nehmen sie nicht in Anspruch
Kinderzuschlag da geht's um Familien die
Arbeiten aber
wenig Einkommen haben 70 Prozent der
Familien die in Anspruch genommen haben
50.000 Kinder Jugendliche die jedes Jahr
die Schule ohne echten Abstand vergessen
sie sagen also da ist eigentlich ein
richtiger Ansatz da wir müssen fördern
müssen Sprachkurse investieren wir
müssen in bessere Integrationen
investieren das ist die Idee dahin genau
das ist die Aussage dahin
Milliarden schweres Programm zur
durchführen
auf den Weg bringen würde oder also das
ist ja das wie passt das dazu
das ausgerechnet bei der Beratung von
Migranten in Sachen Sprachkurse bei der
Arbeitssuche und auch bei der
Kinderbetreuung im kommenden Jahr die
Leistungen um meinen Drittel gekürzt
werden sollen wie passt das zusammen das
ist ja so nicht der Fall sondern sie
meinen ein bestimmtes Programm wo glaube
ich dass Innenministerium Federführung
hat nicht FDP was aber die FDP gerade
werden also unser Punkten der
Kindergrundsicherung Vater ist dass zum
Beispiel die Leistung für Bildung und
Teilhabe dadurch dass sich dieser
Sozialstaat nicht mehr verzettelt sich
völlig über bürokratisiert ist bei den
Familien ankommt das tut er heute
nämlich nicht ich habe die Zahl eben
zitiert unser Ziel in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen ist Geld
sichergestellt zu haben für
besonders gut ausgedattete Schulen ich
nenne das talentschulen ja wenn NRW
nämlich mal erfunden ich war da selber
beteiligt jetzt nennt sich auf
Bundesebene Startchancen Programm da
geht's darum dass wir in die Schulen in
den Stadtteilen wo die sozialen
Herausforderung besonders groß sind
extra Mittel geben dafür kämpft die FDP
also es ist ja nicht so dass wir nicht
dafür tun würden also wenn wir das jetzt
ernst nehmen was er hinten sagt gibt es
sozusagen Frage vielleicht gibt es nach
ihrer Kenntnis das große fdp-programm um
genau das sicher gerade
groß ist dieses Programm dass sie da
draußen Programm ist weit über eine
Milliarde zusätzlich es ist richtig viel
Geld in der aktuellen Haushaltslage das
Thema Bildung und Teilhabe im Bereich
des Sozialstaats da kenne ich mich
wirklich aus ist genau der Punkt auf den
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen die das
fachlich machen und wir seit Monaten
pochen da geht es nämlich um die Frage
wie kriegen wir die Leistung die es gibt
zu den Familien die nutzen die nicht da
muss der Sozialstaat digitaler werden
großes FDP Forderung ein Kinder
chancenportal einzurichten so das sorgt
konkret dafür dass wir die Leistung zu
den Menschen bringen ich war
verantwortlich für eine Arbeitsagentur
ich war verantwortlich für ein Jobcenter
ich kann wirklich sagen wir haben in
diesem Sozialstaat kein Problem damit
dass wir nicht als Gesellschaft
großzügig wären für Menschen die unsere
Unterstützung brauchen sondern wir haben
Probleme damit dass wir in manchen
Bereichen die Menschen nicht in Arbeit
bringen weil z.B das rauswachsen aus der
finanziellen Bedürftigkeit sich nicht
lohnt das ist Sozialstaat komplett vier
konstruiert haben gerade dafür gesorgt
dass zum Beispiel bei Kindern die in
Hörgerät Familien groß werden sich
endlich die das erste selbstverdiente
Geld lohnt denn da wurden die schon
schlechter behandelt so vererben sich
Chancen schlechtere Chancen abhängig von
der Herkunft
und bei der Bildungspolitik machen wir
das selber also das ist wo wir hin
müssen
um die Frage wie viel hat ein Kind zur
Verfügung wie viel haben die Eltern zur
Verfügung um ein Kind auszustatten für
die Schule dem auch ein Hobby zu
ermöglichen genau das ist irgendwie
super Teil und dann ist natürlich die
Unterstützung für Schulen oder die
Weiterbildung für die Eltern ist eine
völlig andere Sache dass das dann
mittelfristig auch dazu führen kann die
Eltern zu ertüchtigen das mag sein aber
dass man überhaupt erstmal sagt wir
möchten dass ein Kind eine bestimmte
Unterstützung hat eine bestimmte mindest
Ausstattung das ist einfach ein Anspruch
gibt dafür einen auch für ein
würdevolles Kinderleben sozusagen das
ist unabhängig für mich von der Frage
wie man die Schulen ausstattet das
stimmt und da ist glaube ich ist der
dezent viel größer und deswegen kam mir
auch Frau Pause mit ihrer aber da ist
anfänglichen irrsinnsforder dieser
Haushalt hat einfach die Leistung
materiell erhöhen das was sie gerade
zurecht ansprechen kann ja diese
ausstatt
zum Beispiel die Frage von Teilhabe ich
mache es mal ganz lebensnah und konkret
kann ich am Schulausflug teilnehmen oder
muss ich sagen ich bin nicht dabei weil
meine Eltern weniger Geld haben kann ich
in den Sportverein gehen oder muss ich
verschämt zu Hause bleiben und habe das
Gefühl nicht gleichberechtigt teilhaben
können in dieser Gesellschaft da geht's
um die sogenannten Leistung für Bildung
und Teilhabe und das ist genau was ich
eben zitiert habe die haben wir in
Deutschland die sind da aber dieser
sozialstand ist so verzettelt so
bürokratisiert dass 80 % der Familien
denen das zusteht
genau das ist äh nicht nur unstreitig
sondern auch gar nicht persönlich seit
vielen Jahren sage und wir haben den
letzten Monaten gesagt haben das ist was
Kinder Grundsicherung konkret heißt dass
das wirklich bei den in den ankommt ich
kann jetzt aus der Praxis schildern
seit 24 Jahren Hamburg Jugendarbeit in
den Stadtteilen wo halt nicht eben das
geboten ist so und es ist so wahnsinnig
erniedrigend da betteln zu müssen
hingehen zu müssen und es ist so
kompliziert ihr könnt das gar nicht
vorstellen so kompliziert ein bisschen
Geld für den Ausflug noch zu bekommen
dass die am Ende sagen da gehe ich gar
nicht hin ich muss mich ja auch nackig
machen ich muss ja sagen was ich sonst
irgendwie da habe es ist erniedrigen ich
hoffe nur dass die Veränderung jetzt
dieses dieses neue Gesetz auch dafür
sorgt dass die Bürokratie da abgebaut
wird dass sie sich verschlagen
Digitalisierung Digitalisierung ist
immer das Thema
Digitalisierung aber schwieriger als
geklärt muss man ja sagen oder im Moment
ist ja das soll ja diese neue diese neue
Familienservice werden man sie kennen
sich da eine viel besser aus bei der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit angesiedelt
aber das da sozusagen wie diese Struktur
jetzt zusammenarbeitet mit den
Jobcentern und wie man das irgendwie
unter einen Hut kriegt das ist doch noch
alles andere
ich habe eine Frage in dem Zusammenhang
stimmt es dass der Finanzminister plant
die Ausgaben für Computer und Software
im Bereich Verwaltung des Bundes von 377
Millionen auf 3,3 Millionen Euro zu
kürzen das habe ich noch nie gehört
gucke ich mir gerne an weiß ich aber
nicht der Haushaltsaufstellung läuft ja
so die Regierung hat den Haushalt
verabschiedet und nicht der
Finanzminister entscheidet weil jedes
Detail sondern es gibt konkrete Töpfe
für einzelne Ministerien und Sie müssen
mir sagen welches Ministerium da
zuständig ist zuständig aber das ist aus
dem Topf des BMI das ist Teil des
Sparprogramms
ja das ist ja immer das gleiche
argumentative Struktur dass der Lindner
sagt ich kann ja nichts dafür wo die
Leute sparen aber wenn er natürlich den
Leuten sagt bitte ihr müsst jetzt so und
so viel Milliarden einsparen das ist ja
so kam er diese elterngeldkürzung bei
Frau Pause Zustande dann gibt es nur
bestimmte Kostenblöcke wo du überhaupt
anfangen kannst abzuschmelzen ne das
waren ja auch er hat ja auch
Empfehlungen geschickt war doch mal hier
Spar doch mal da und dann findest
schwierig nachher zu sagen ja ich kann
ja nichts dafür wenn die dann
tatsächlich alle sparen so ich sage ja
nur geht ja nur den Rahmen vor ja aber
der Rahmen ist ja der der die Zwänge
erzeugt also ich meinte ganz ernst
Interesse der Haushalt kommt ja jetzt
erst ins Parlament wir machen jetzt die
Haushaltsverhandlungen sowas finde ich
wirklich als Anregung wichtig weil wir
gucken uns das an so aber eins will ich
kurz sagen erstens dieser Haushalt hat
90 Milliarden mehr als vor Corona vor
den Krisen also ist nicht so das ist
kein Sparhaushalt aber was nötig ist und
worauf der Finanzminister Hinweis ist
dass die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten ist
die steht nämlich nicht nur in der
Verfassung sondern dahinter steht ja ein
Gedanke der Gedanke für den Staat geht
was für uns alle gilt und alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu Hause man
kommt mit dem Geld aus was man hat und
wenn wir generell finden wir brauchen
noch mehr Mittel sollten wir uns umso
mehr Gedanken machen wir verbessern wir
die Rahmenbedingungen in diesem Land für
Wachstum und Wettbewerbsfähigkeit das
große Start Sprachkurse Integration wann
starten Sie dieses neue große Programm
um Leute besser an den Arbeitsmarkt zu
bringen also Leute ohne deutschen Pass
der Punkt für Bildung und Teilhabe dass
die Mittel ankommen bei den Familien ist
genau was ich jetzt erwarte von dieser
Kindergrundsicherung
richtig großes dickes einen Bums ein
echtes Programm um zu sagen wir sorgen
jetzt dafür dass die Eltern über die
Herr Lindner spricht dass die jetzt
wirklich im deutschen Arbeitsmarkt
angekommen doch ich kann Ihnen drei
Punkte nennen erstens Kinder
chancenportal ist unser Vorschlag dafür
dass diese Leistung ankommt zweitens wir
sorgen dafür dass Menschen in die
finanzielle Selbstständigkeit kommen
dadurch dass sich stärker lohnt dass sie
rauswachsen das ist in aus der Praxis
ein ganz konkretes Problem in der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik das ist super unfair
zeigte sich sogar bei den Kindern bei
der Erfahrung des ersten selbst
verdienten Geldes haben wir gerade schon
korrigiert jetzt wollen wir was für
anderes auch noch korrigieren das dritte
ist talentschulen Milliarde schweres
Programm um bei den Schulen in den
Stadtteilen mit den größeren sozialen
Herausforderungen endlich mehr zu tun
weil draußen Gerechtigkeit ist in diesem
Land eine riesiges Problem viel
schlechter als in anderen Industrie
Ländern und das treibt mich als
Liberalen um das das versteht mich
trotzdem meine letzte Frage zu dem Thema
aber man kann sich darin verlieren
kinderarmut ist unglaublich komplex ja
und nicht so einfach wie es da auch
teilweise dargestellt wird und auch
diese Zusammenhänge sind nicht so
eindeutig wenn das letzte Woche hier in
der Sendung und wir haben uns noch mal
intensiv war damit beschäftigt ist
wirklich interessant es gibt nach wie
vor mehr deutsche Kinder die vom
Bürgergeld abhängig sind als Kinder die
keinen deutschen Pass haben ja 900.000
und ein paar haben keinen deutschen Pass
etwas über eine Millionen haben einen
deutschen Pass
also dieser Zusammenhang der da
sozusagen suggeriert wird wir haben da
jetzt ein riesiges Thema weil wir so
viele ausländische Kinder haben der ist
so nicht richtig aber was dahinter
den Punkt machen
und die Frage nach der Statistik ist ja
sehr interessant
es wird sozusagen der Eindruck erweckt
wir haben politisch richtig etwas
abgeräumt wir haben für Kinder mit
deutschen Pass wirklich etwas getan weil
die Zahlen das sagt die Statistik
deutlich zurückgegangen sind innerhalb
der letzten 10 15 Jahre
wenn man da mal genauer hinguckt wenn
man mit Statistikern spricht dann sagen
die in folgendes der Grund warum diese
deutschen Kinder in dieser Statistik
nicht mehr auftauchen als
armutsgefährdet ist ganz einfach durch
die starke Zuwanderung der letzten Jahre
ist das mögliche Einkommen hat sich nach
unten verschoben und diese Kinder sind
schlicht aus der Statistik rausgefallen
das heißt aber nicht
nur einen einzigen Euro mehr haben als
sie vorher hatten das ist keine
politische glanzt hat das ist keine
politische Leistung das ist einfach nur
aus der Abteilung ich baue jetzt meine
Statistik so wie sie mir passt die haben
aber gerade
das gehört so weit dazu zwei Statistiken
ineinander gerührt das eine ist nie wer
kriegt Bürger Geld Grundsicherung
genau da und warum spricht man das an
weil es doch auch finde ich ein Zeichen
für die Solidarität unserer Gesellschaft
ist dass wir so viele Flüchtlinge zum
Beispiel Ukraine aufgenommen haben die
Frage was machen wir jetzt dass die da
rauskommen da entsteht dann erst die
politische Debatte zweitens so was Sie
beschrieben haben ist das zweite ist
Armutsgefährdung da geht es um die
Einkommensverteilung unserer
Gesellschaft und natürlich wünsche ich
mir wie sie hoffentlich und wie wir alle
hoffentlich dass Menschen die nicht in
der Grundsicherung sind aber die weniger
Einkommen haben aufsteigen können sich
was aufbauen können daraus wachsen
können und dann bleibt aber trotzdem im
nächsten Schritt wieder die Frage was
können wir politisch dafür tun unter
glaube ich
insgesamt Wirtschaftswachstum ist die
Voraussetzung
reicht aber nicht weil dann müssen
Menschen auch ganz individuell
Aufstiegschancen haben da geht's Bildung
sich Materialien
ist da gibt es diese Kinder mit
deutschen Pass und die sind jetzt
deutlich weniger haben uns gefährdet
Klammer auf sind sie gar nicht und ist
auch das Gefühl dass da draußen ganz
ganz viele haben die sagen was erzählen
die da eigentlich ich kämpfe jeden Tag
um um mein kleines Leben und das Leben
meiner Kinder und die will mir dass
meine Kinder weil sie den deutschen Pass
haben deutlich weniger armutsgefährdet
sind als es noch vor 15 Jahren aber das
hat doch gar niemand gesagt aber das ist
das was der Eindruck der damit erweckt
wird und dann haben wir ganz viele
Zuwanderer dann haben wir ganz viele
Menschen die dazugekommen sind und da
haben wir ein echtes Problem und dann
müssen wir jetzt mal gucken und spielen
an dem Punkt und das ist meine Kritik an
dem Punkt spielen wir die beide
plötzlich auf eine Art und Weise
gegeneinander aus die ich nicht okay
finde lass uns doch noch einmal in
diesen Ton reinhören weil das ein
zentrale Ersatz ist und sehr interessant
für die Frage wie geht man dann am Ende
auch um mit der AFD also sozusagen
da ist das Problem und es ist vor allen
Dingen bei den Ausländern kann man so
beschreiben aber dann muss man
ehrlicherweise auch sagen was man
dagegen zu tun gedenkt oder das war
genau der Satz
in Deutschland ist die Kinderarmut
deutlich zurückgegangen
ganz ganz deutlich spürbar
zurückgegangen
bei den ursprünglich deutschen Familien
die schon länger hier sind
insgesamt ist in Deutschland die
Kinderarmut aber noch vergleichsweise
und wie ich finde ihn diskutabel hoch
wegen der Familien die seit 2015 neu
nach Deutschland eingewandert sind
als geflüchtete oder aus anderen Gründen
es gibt also ein ganz klaren
statistischen Zusammenhang zwischen
Zuwanderung und Kinderarmut wie helfe
ich am besten den Kindern und
Jugendlichen
hilft man Ihnen am besten dadurch dass
man den Eltern mehr Geld aufs Konto
überweist oder ist nicht vielleicht
mindestens diskussionswürdig in die
Sprachförderung Integration
Beschäftigungsfähigkeit der Eltern zu
investieren und die Kitas und Schulen
für die Kinder so auszustatten dass sie
vielleicht das Aufholen können was die
Eltern nicht leisten können
[Applaus]
wie haben sie das verstanden ich würde
eher interessieren wie Herr Vogel sieht
oder also ich finde schon dass da ein
eine ein bisschen eine Kategorisierung
eingeführt wird dass da gesagt wird für
die sozusagen die deutschen Kinder sind
nicht das Problem und die sozusagen die
ausländischen Familien sind das Problem
und gar nicht in dem Sinne dass er gegen
die Stimmung machen möchte sondern dass
er erklärt daraus ableiten möchte was
seine Antworten auf das Thema
Kinderarmut sind und seine Antworten auf
das Thema Kinderarmut ist eben nicht
Geld für die bedürftigen Familien
sondern für die Strukturen wenn man
soweit an die Strukturen rangehen das
ist ja auch vernünftig an Strukturen
dran zu gehen aber die Frage ob man
nicht trotzdem eine gewisse
Grundausstattung ob die an sich
sozusagen dass das Haushaltsbudget das
solchen Familien zur Verfügung steht ob
man nicht das da zusätzlich ran muss das
ist ja denke ich auch der Punkt von
Pause deswegen hatte sie ja auch diese
Riesensumme am Anfang in den Raum
gestellt die vielleicht auch ein
bisschen verrückt war aber trotzdem ist
das ja wenn man mal ausrechnet wie viel
ein Kind braucht wirklich um würde ich
aufzuwachsen kommt man sehr schnell in
riesige Beträge
das ist der Satz
ist der entscheidende weggelassen
noch mal ich erinnere von Kinderarmut ja
und Kinderarmut in Deutschland ich sage
es nochmal ist deswegen vor allen Dingen
zurückgegangen weil das mittlere
Einkommen gesunken ist die sind aus der
Statistik gefallen Herr Lanz ich mag
mich nicht mit ihnen streiten aber ich
kenne mich wirklich in der Sozialpolitik
aus sie verwischen Kind Armut da geht's
um Grundsicherung das ist
Existenzminimum und der Fachbegriff für
das was sie meinen ist Armutsgefährdung
das ist die Einkommensverteilung weißt
du übrigens würde genau so bleiben wenn
alle eine Million mehr haben als heute
wer trotzdem die Verteilung gleich und
die Armutsgefährdung der Leuten wäre da
obwohl sie das zeigt schon dass diese
Statistik auch
diskussionswürdig ist jedenfalls zwei
verschiedene Paar Schuhe es geht um die
Menschen in der Grundsicherung und um
die Frage der Einkommensverteilung so
und bei den Menschen in der
Grundsicherung müssen uns die Frage
stellen wie bringen wir da die raus und
das zweite ist wie schaffen wir es dass
die Einkommensverteilung die Schere in
Deutschland nicht immer weiter
auseinandergeht so und da glaube ich
geht's zum Beispiel darum dass die
Sozialleistung die diesen Menschen zur
Verfügung stehen Kinderzuschlag ist das
zum Beispiel heute dass die auch von den
beiden Menschen ankommt das wieder so
ein Beispiel dafür dass du Sozialstaat
nicht größer werden muss was die
Leistungsniveaus angeht sondern
treffsicherer nicht fetter fitter damit
das bei den Menschen ankommt und
zweitens würde ich mir gerne die Frage
stellen wie sorgen wir eigentlich dafür
dass generell die Einkommensschere in
Deutschland nicht immer weiter
auseinander geht vor allem die
eigentumsschere nicht immer weiter
auseinander geht also Aufstiegschancen
wie sorgen wäre dafür dass Menschen sich
was aufbauen können Eigenheim wie sorgen
wir dafür dass alle Menschen in Aktien
sparen können damit Sie sich auch ein
kleines Eigentum aufbauen können diese
Debatten würde ich gerne führen und das
zweite Problem zu lösen und wir sorgen
wir dafür im dritten auch noch dabei
sind dass die Menschen gar nicht erst
mit so unterschiedlichen Startchancen
ins Leben kommen wegen der Familie der
Herkunft in die sie geboren wurden